curious to know how fantastic four
co-stars miles teller and michael b
jordan figure into a potential third
installment in the top gun franchise
keep watching to find out there was a
time when the idea of pete maverick
mitchell climbing back into the cockpit
was little more than a nostalgia pipe
dream incredibly though top good
maverick has been prepping for takeoff
since 2010 when producer jerry
bruckheimer and the late director tony
scott were planning a sequel focus on
the prevalence of drone warfare that
concept never took flight though and
over a decade and a global pandemic
later we can now finally see cruz's
legendary flyboy soar into a sequel
that's as good or even better than the
movie that came before it taking us to
new heights and bringing in a band of
fresh aviators top gun maverick propels
into unexpected territory and leaves us
asking the previously unthinkable can it
go any further i feel the need
for me
[Music]
seeing as it took over 30 years for a
sequel to the iconic 80s movie to
materialize some might think that
there's no reason to hope that a third
installment will be gearing up for
takeoff anytime soon but given the
considerable buzz top gun maverick has
generated in the lead up to its release
and the fact that we're in an era when
sequels and franchises are all the rage
perhaps we shouldn't be so cynical while
it's not like he's struggling for
billion dollar franchises to be a part
of maverick is proof that crews can
breathe life back into any film
franchise in the case of his latest
airborne adventure could topgo maverick
bring its mile high heroes back for
another pass having already been a hit
with both critics and audiences
expectations are high that a return
flight to the world of top gun would
translate to some big numbers after all
tom cruise is still standing running and
flying as one of the most bankable stars
in hollywood and with top gun maverick
already expected to bring in between 255
million dollars and 390 million dollars
at the domestic box office according to
projections by box office pro and
there's every chance it could exceed
those expectations of course when in the
business of blockbusters an occasional
success story can spawn an even bigger
one and the open slot for a third top
gun film could come at a crucial time
for the studio behind the movie with
mere days before the big takeoff of top
gun maverick paramount released a
trailer for the next installment of the
other blockbuster property cruisers
headlined for decades mission impossible
dead reckoning part 1 guaranteed to
boast even more dangerous stunts than
the tense espionage lace escapades that
came before the two-part dead reckoning
installment of the beloved spy franchise
will mark the final chapter for ethan
hunt as it has been described as a
wrap-up for the series if this really is
the end of imf paramount's mission
should they choose to accept it is to
find another franchise to fill the [ __ ]
one that can also cash in on cruz's star
power even if he may not necessarily
always need to be front and center for
potential future installments
before maverick flies off into the
sunset a brand new squad of top guns
have been tested in combat and proven
themselves more than capable of going
back out without their teacher to see
that happen in a future top gun film
would be a bold maneuver but it's one
that miles tellers former fantastic four
co-star michael b jordan could certainly
give a few pointers on given the success
he's had with another franchise that has
been revived for a new generation
whereas some legacy equals have
attempted to reignite a property under
the same name but with an all-new cast
the different approach by bringing back
his titular character but allowing a new
challenger to step forward and usher in
a fresh era
creed sees michael b jordan stepping
into the ring to tell a whole new story
that follows directly in the footsteps
of sylvester stallone's legendary boxer
who returned for the first two films of
the spin-off trilogy albeit in a
supporting role with this in mind
there's no reason why this newly revived
franchise couldn't follow suit by the
end of top gun maverick the likes of
phoenix hangman and barbara all
characters should be happy to see take
off again and maverick doesn't
necessarily need to be front and center
between tellers honorable hero and
powwows suave glory hugging wiseguy
there's a whole host of characters and
heroes in the making we'd be happy to
follow back into the danger zone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one